hello everybody my name is why
markiplier and welcome to the arrow
dodge challenge we are uncomfortably
close because we love you and also
because this camera seems to be having
some problems but either way we're gonna
be doing the arrow dodge challenge we
got done with the water bottle flip
challenge and it was a lot of fun we had
an arrow component but not a Dodge
component so we're gonna take turns
shooting at each other up on the stage
over there which is currently empty show
the stage
yep it's empty our etiquette what a good
stage that is the shooting range where
we'll be dying but for every arrow that
does not kill us meaning we don't get it
we get a point whoever has the most
points at the end wins and then we'll
figure something else out as we go along
okay break teen you get a point
yeah silent Tyler
alright so we're gonna do rock paper
suits to see who goes first I guess it's
up freedom Kay rock paper scissors well
hi but not gonna first not going first
that's for damn sure
above I'm off alright I'll join ha ok ok
[Music]
ah I go first no kizer's cuts help the
reason Tyler's up there is because he
didn't get a single arrow shot at him in
the last challenge so we're just gonna
go for him and a half backwards
bad story yep here we go are you ready
yes all right slowly kill them all Oh Oh
the right knee is oh yeah nice shot
oh right in the ayahs but listen is he
all right for the tick this time he's
asking for it you can see by the way
he's dressed
he's asking for hey was shot it was got
to happen
a lethal wasn't they hit me twice yeah
you got hit twice
any last words oh man
oh so hot [ __ ] wait you know I always
thought you were a handsome devil I know
now that I see I see your [ __ ] ugly it's
[ __ ] yeah you better be careful what you
say whoa Oh
ha ha ha I ready jump back that way a
new hip hip ooh oh you want me jumped in
glad to stop myself hard whoo
there comes down to me break the tie oh
I'm gonna get ya
oh man ok so I made it with just two
hits house cry are you wait we'll find
out very strong full rubbery all right I
love you
you're a handsome devil and you have
lovely hair thank you and frankly you
are just
[Applause]
he's got me guys another one of our team
come in oh that's nice I don't know that
she'll says no you got hit yeah that's
what that counts as if you catch it out
of your teeth maybe huh yeah try
catching with your teeth that's fun oh
whoa whoa [ __ ] crews this is serious
okay so we accidentally broke the
neighbors lamp which is great but he's
super nice we offered to pay for it he
was like oh no fine
so your questions over there hi and
thank you
being nice we'll finish this up and try
not to break anything else Bob no more
get a second one overnight into it oh
okay we're getting back into it wait
still up there he's not off the block I
can't see anything the glares gotten so
much worse than I was here before when
you are a shining example of everything
wrong with society what you have had a
left
oh good escape get so far well not
really that's a lot give me the pool
I cut the hood I don't want to talk back
boy him Wow - section immediately yeah I
caught the one I got hit by yeah yeah
that was pretty good a little bit thick
weights in the lead I won't hit anybody
though okay when you got a hit people
all right we got a small target coming
up here oh you cannot see it oh oh this
is so scary [ __ ] I can't see one head
I've lost an arm oh no no you pick that
arm back out there and stick it back out
oh I'm afraid please don't go foot power
Tyler please spare me Wow then close to
me hey boss Bob you're a nice guy no why
were you moving when I wasn't even doing
I don't know why am i spending my energy
like ready big boy when you not can you
not do it super hard why you pulling it
back so much oh boy oh it got my butt on
the way back muffled big boy back up on
campus you whatcha get I'm very sorry
zit I think Tyler really wants me I just
don't
this is don't do it super hard Tyler
please
Oh No so everybody you don't get another
one you don't get a mulligan this is not
golf oh yeah that's a good job working
no no Mulligan's help do it like that
go ahead Bob you're aiming you're aiming
low there you are how many times do you
hit twice please have you got it or not
oh we got a present thank you
so I got hit a lot but we'll count it
back but you're definitely in the lead
for being heavy yeah it's a lot more
scary than you think
ready sure all right
no are you excited for when I shoot no
oh one hit I'm sorry easy man I'm sorry
Bob
you don't have to be intimidated you
cannot shoot as hard as well he just
steps up and it's scary very nice to me
so I'm not gonna be very nice to you
once in the foot we don't have to talk
about what you did it was what your
intentions were my intentions of the
same got some tricks up my sleeve look
if I want to tie
have to hit him I've got a hit I'm still
the best dog if I don't hit this I lose
and then I get here we go out of here a
lot and I gotta channel my energy no
even no I think even because I hated the
best qualifications not even trying to
[ __ ] up are you trying before is I hurts
no crap yeah free video please don't
lower the bow you're gonna screw it up
again just aim oh my god they can't hold
it for long bottom i either yes down
George oh thank you for that so he can
lost because I don't know what happened
do a statistical analysis of what the
hell happened Oh like a smallest target
mm-hmm I'm calculating what happened you
got hit the most happen out there
I'm the smallest target I'm probably the
most spry person here yeah and I lost
you used to be I got you didn't even
take an opportunity to do backflip on oh
why would I
whatever we're all gonna shoot him so
get up there I want to be wearing a cup
okay this looks great
this does not look great I don't know
where you're talking about this looks
horrible we're not gonna shoot everyone
just hold your bows like up and ready
boats are this is the most intimidating
[Music]
and fired will oh you're supposed to
gosh there's new horses that I can't
dodge these there's too many of them no
yeah this is not fun she's a horrible
time this is a horrible time please do
glad you moved Ella look how you dodge
before you ready oh we're ready you know
I think we should redo this shot oh yeah
I think I need a better thumbnail the
camera stuff yeah whatever you do
although we're talking uniform shot hey
argh it's the final shot why are you
going so close get on your knees turn
around
hey guys don't look guys don't look at
this one you want through the harder
through the head you did not get a
fourth shot I fired way over there
firing squad
now anyway that was the arrow dodge
challenge thank you everybody so much
for watching thank you everybody for
participating ah
the score is mmm - booth winner being
and the loser beam oh we know you're a
TV we know a lot champion yeah thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always we'll see you
in an extra copy to throw below those
others I be standing by my god I didn't
see your arm moves just all of a sudden
raining narrowed move I thought the
neighbor was getting repaired
[Music]